[Music]
all right it is the day before tomorrow
tomorrow is a very important and big day
for Isaac how come you have bubblegum
right there what is that what is that
what is that today and tomorrow is gonna
be the last day I can chew gum just I'm
gonna get braces Maurice's let me see
those cute right now two years from now
they're gonna be straight you excited
yeah but I'm not looking forward to how
people's mum said um like when they're
when they tightened it like her skull
hurt and I feel like I felt that before
mm-hmm like I think I had a dream about
getting raises so what did it feel like
in your dream my school hurt okay so in
preparation of Isaac getting braces
I got him some hubba bubba well then one
thing that you can't do with braces is
chew bubblegum so I got you a hole I
said it's at a foot long how long is
that there's like six feet of fun six
feet oh hey yeah six feet of fun to chew
before in braces Tahoe yeah that's a lot
of chewing okay and then also got apples
cuz you can't eat apples with braces cuz
they'll pop off the brackets and then
you had a special request for takis BAM
true hey that's a pretty good snack
right there Tasha
Apple for nutrition and what will gum
for dessert all right what do you want
to do first every time I get stuck you
guys are always with Chris
mm-hmm I can taste how a nutritious this
is mmm
find dangerous test stop eating this bar
you can't stop mm-hmm by the way hmm
this floor is clean so I dropped the
taki five-second rule so I feel like I
finished a baguette - I know are you
thirsty afterwards yeah this stuff gets
you thirsty
okay I got this when your hands turn
stop holding your mouth where I felt
like chewing gum I get it
you know what's even more gross I would
have hum discovered a collection of like
I mean I'd be like half asleep to I'm
like I don't know how to put this I just
stick my hand around the headboard and I
would just have like all my boogers
there having a collection boogers oh
yeah I tried putting my my gum in the
back of my head what I'm in a headboard
just head not that well so excited for
you man you won't be able to do that oh
good morning my boy good morning today
is the last full day that you get to
live without breathing for the next two
years
then with your teeth
geez yeah do you need braces
oh they're gonna feature oh yeah we
could be thinking this the video is poor
quality Pablo please you're excited yeah
not yet what is gonna hurt ya you okay
any friends of yours in school have
braces yeah yeah where did they say did
you ask him but he wasn't like one of my
friends said it Skinner her for like the
first day
excited I'm sure to lick your teeth now
yeah like you move your your cheeks
around your your lips that's the last
time you'll ever be able to do that
until two years from now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you decide to get work done - yes Mike
you ship it a lot after Grace's has
really been married and erupts and bliss
I felt like the last words of Donna's
you really fix my jaw like my Johnson
really back so I really wanted to
[Music]
close feels a little weird on the lips
right
[Music]
like how you're moving your lips around
[Music]
my mirror I bet the water hand the back
okay I see that very how does that feel
okay so it's crazy feel the pressure a
little bit buddy yeah at least we know
what's working nice MC Dan look at that
very cool
what do you think I like them that's
good
just get all in there so you're you know
the cheese no fighting
you gonna do complete the look ask your
new look right there all right so if
braces are in how you feeling oh yeah
look at that
oh thank you voices get deeper - way
deeper whoa yeah well yeah that's kind
of cool and they let you chew gum
I know I've never heard of that before I
did not think that they're gonna allow
for gum imma turn on the lights
best sugar-free gum this cool oh my god
my baby boy has braces oh my gosh
I feel old man this is crazy this is
crazy
do you take a photo and send it to your
dad let's go back a little bit or just
strain on your wreck
get closer
[Laughter]
[Music]
so yeah dang your boys did get deeper
what happened oh my gosh it's so cool
cuz the bracelets Aggie has they're like
way more higher yeah but nothing less
you actually smiled and show your teeth
like I think you could talk to people
wouldn't even notice
how you doing it alright so you can't
even see them let's go get food alright
something soft
nice and soft for your braces
[Music]
my house you like eating well with your
braces Nemco wears like a little pocket
every time I yeah it hurt yet your piece
very nice is your food stuck in your
mouth and your braces now try to meet
the meeting to get stuck with Isaac
having braces we're not able to eat
anything no more fried chicken for us
no more barbecue for us more work for us
you're a baby that has a deep voice
[Music]
[Music]